bienvenidos problema número 237 a un
empleado de medio tiempo le aumentaron
un 25% su pago por hora él decide
disminuir el número de horas que trabaja
de manera que su sueldo semanal se
mantenga igual en qué porcentaje se
reducen sus horas de trabajo semanal
anotemos los datos ese es el sueldo por
hora y h es las horas que trabaja la
semana esto es igual a el aumento que
tuvo de
25% en el sueldo por el número de horas
que quiere reducir en cierta fracción
que voy a llamar x esta persona no
quiere cambiar lo que gana por semana
está ese de sueldo se va con ésta todos
estamos duplicando y aquí también
tenemos horas y horas de este lado que
también se van por lo que nos queda que
uno es igual a 1.25 por equis despejemos
x lo que nos interesa saber es este
porcentaje esta variable este 1.25 lo
puedo expresar infracciones y me
convienen más porque es más fácil de
manipular así esto igual a punto 25 es
un cuarto un entero son cuatro cuartos
cuatro cuartos más un cuarto son cinco
cuartos de equis y ahora multiplico todo
por el recíproco de esto que es cuatro
quintos x es igual a cuatro quintos y
cuatro quintos es igual a 0.8 esas son
las horas que está trabajando ahora que
le aumentaron el sueldo queremos ver en
cuánto se redujo el total de horas así
que si trabaja el 80% de las horas
originales redujo sus horas un 20% que
es mi opción de siguiente problema
problema número 238 la región sombreada
de la siguiente figura es un marco
rectangular el marco encuadra una foto
rectangular que tiene la misma área que
el marco si las dimensiones de la foto
tienen la misma proporción que el marco
cuál es la longitud de la foto nos están
preguntando la longitud
esta es la longitud este es la altura de
este cuadro que tiene la misma
proporción que este otro y como las
proporciones son iguales el lado entre
la altura va a ser igual a 18 entre 15 y
esto lo simplificamos es igual a 6 entre
5 y también nos dicen que el área del
cuadro de la foto es la misma que el
área del cuadro del marco recordemos que
el marco es esta parte amarilla el área
es lado por alto igual a 15 por 18 cuál
es el área de este marco pues va a ser
esta área o este cuadro grande - el área
de la foto y el área de la foto es l por
al menos el x a sumamos ambos lados con
el epp ahora y nos va a quedar 2 l x a
igual a 15 por 18 dividimos todo entre 2
me va a quedar que el lado por la altura
es igual a 15 por 18 entre 2 18 entre
dos es igual a 9 así esto es igual a 15
por 9 ahora tenemos dos ocasiones con
dos incógnitas como me interesa
encontrar el vamos a sustituir a
recordamos que seis quintos es igual a
él entre a despejó a y va a ser igual a
cinco sextos de él y esto lo voy a
sustituir acá el por a pero hay cinco
sextos dl por cinco sextos dl es igual a
15 por 9 15 por 9 multiplicamos todo por
el recíproco de éste por seis quintos y
me va a quedar que l al cuadrado es
igual a 15 por 9 por 6 entre 5 15 y 35
estrés me queda que esto es igual a 3
por 9 por 6 y por las opciones que tengo
me conviene factorizar este 6 como 3 por
es 3 por 9 27 por
381 esto es igual a 81 por 2 y ahora
como me interesa el l va a ser igual a
la raíz cuadrada de todo esto raíz
cuadrada de 81 por 2 pero esto lo puedo
expresar como raíz cuadrada de 81 por la
raíz cuadrada de 2 y la raíz cuadrada de
81 es 9 esto es igual a 9 por raíz de 2
que es mi opción siguiente problema
problema número 239 de 200 estudiantes
130 estudian química y 150 estudian
biología si al menos 30 estudiantes no
estudian esas materias entonces el
número de estudiantes de química y
biología está en el rango de vamos a
dibujar esto como un diagrama de ven
tenemos aquí a los estudiantes que
estudian química que son 130 aquí
tenemos a los estudiantes que estudian
jia que son 150 y aquí va a estar el
resto de los estudiantes que no estudian
ninguna de estas dos materias y nos
dicen que es de al menos 30 estudiantes
esto es de al menos 30 y estos son mis
200 estudiantes supongamos que el resto
es exactamente igual a 30 para
simplificar nuestro análisis si esto es
30 cuántos estudian química o biología
pues serán 170 vamos a poner esto de acá
la intersección de los que estudian
química y biología la voy a llamar y de
intersección y llamaremos a este resto x
si sumamos los de química y biología los
de química que son 130 más los de
biología que son 150 estaré sumando esta
intersección dos veces por lo que debo
restarle una vez menos y así que todo
esto se refiere a los que estudian
química o biología o ambos
y sabemos que esto debe ser igual a 200
x que son los que no están estudiando
ninguna de estas materias esto es igual
a 200 menos x vamos a tratar de despejar
la intersección que es lo que nos
preguntan en términos de x 130 más 150
es 280 menos sin igual a 200 menos x
restamos 200 en ambos lados queda 80
menos sin igual a menos x y sumamos si
en ambos lados 80 es igual a y menos x
como me interesa ahí voy a sumar x en
ambos lados y va a ser igual a 80 más x
y xi
quedamos que es mayor o igual a 30
entonces está ahí debe ser mayor o igual
a 80 x
110 este es el límite inferior de la
intersección ahora cuál es el límite
superior pues el límite superior será
130 así es que todos los que estudian
química también estudiarán biología no
podemos tener a los 150 de biología
estudiando química porque estos son solo
130 por lo que la intersección está en
el rango de 110 menor o igual a la
intersección menor o igual a 130 que es
mi opción de y nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo